diving this tomb is so high risk that
we're sending an underwater Hammer drone
in first to see if it's even
possible you guys ready yeah we're ready
let me see how far I can get it down
maybe I can get it right to the entrance
copy here we go I got video feed well
King nasan we come with good intentions
to tell your
story please take care of
us
all
right I'm sing
now I'll try to get you right to the
entrance
okay he's dragging it down now
[Music]
mhm
okay it's pretty far out there
yeah a this is gnarly I can't see
anything okay I'm going to get you right
to the entrance and let go okay okay y
line it up
straight
[Music]
you get there yeah I think I'm
in let's see how it looks on the camera
all right moving
forwards this is such a challenging
environment to navigate through
you can barely see anything and it just
glimmers here we go here we go it's
opening up a little
bit so that's a corner of one of the
chambers all right real subtle light
movements
now look right there oh what is that I
think that's the top of the door going
into the third chamber so this is where
the king would have been buried we are
in the burial chamber all right look
there that's the left side of the slab
wow and this is either the corner of the
top of a platform on which the king
would have been buried or it's the top
of some sort of casing for the king you
barely make it out though through the
mar Just a glimpse right but it's good
news we know we're in the third chamber
then we know that each of the entrance
ways to each chamber is clear you know
safe yeah so I think we're going to have
to get in there somehow this gives us
good information and lets us know we can
at least navigate in and out
space inside this fragile tomb is
extremely tight prioritizing the
protection of the Tomb there's only room
for Pierce Paul and his support diver if
you can find any clues that can tell us
anything about who he is or where he
came from that's what we're looking for
we'll go in we'll see what we can find
and bring out what we
[Music]
got as the scanning team continue their
3D modeling of the
site we get set to search the flooded
tomb all right guys good
[Music]
luck it must be entering the third
chamber
now hoping this is where we find what
we're looking
for what is that in his hand right
there okay he's back at the
surface what oh that was a
[Music]
face